well the media and and in the left and
Democrats I mean these are all the same
people of course but they have exercised
no restraint this week when it comes to
blaming President Trump for the pipe
bombs that have been mailed to I think
we're up to about 12 different people
now at this point they blame Trump they
blamed Republicans generally for the for
the rhetoric which allegedly has has led
to this and in fact CNN even announced
that they what they had up on there on
their screen yesterday it said that the
intending the intended recipients of the
bombs were Trump's targets so that's the
words they used that the but that bomber
was sending these bombs to Trump's
targets as if as if Trump had contracted
this person whoever it is to send these
to send these these bombs up NBC ran a
headline today saying their headline was
Trump slams pipe bomb recipient CNN in
overnight tweet pipe bomb recipient CNN
that's quite an interesting way to
describe to describe CNN obviously
trying to insinuate that there's
something you know there's something
reckless or something wrong with Trump
criticizing CNN because someone mailed a
pipe bomb to them I got to tell you I
don't really see the connection there I
think it's bad that somebody mail the
pipe onto CNN I don't approve of that I
think it's a very terrible evil thing
but just because that happened it
doesn't mean that now we're not allowed
to criticize CNN what kind of a what
kind of mentality is that I mean it's
it's it's absolutely absurd but this is
what we're getting this is what we're
getting from the media in an MSNBC
anchor yesterday insisted very directly
that this culture of toxic rhetoric
started with Trump that's what she said
it's he it's he started it it all began
with him you know the way it was a
utopia before him everyone agreed
everyone got along there was no
disagreement and there was no toxic
rhetoric and then Trump came along and
he started all of it didn't exist before
him this is all his fault that's what
the left to say
judging by the media's reaction to the
story this week you might think if you
didn't know any better
if you just dropped here from outer
space and you were looking around and
you were looking at the news coverage of
these of these these devices that have
been that have been Sentra you might
think that this is the first example of
political violence or attempt attempted
violence anyway in years and you might
think that every example has been
committed at the hands of right-wingers
that that's what you would think from
the way that from from the reaction
that's what you would probably think but
of course you would think wrong there
are many examples we could point to of
left-wing violence and this is not what
about ISM okay this is not like that's
not what this is about this is about
being honest and also understanding the
scope of the problem and also getting an
idea of how our media operates so let's
just run through a few examples here
because the point is these these
examples I'm gonna give although these
things happened the media they the media
didn't want to have any conversation
about toxic rhetoric back then they
didn't blame it on the Democrats nothing
like that
even though let's just go through let's
go through well here's here's a recent
one that was I think it was it was in
the news for about 12.5 seconds but
ricin was sent to President Trump and
other administration officials this
happened just a few weeks ago as I said
it was in the news for a very brief time
and then it was forgotten
now of course Trump was he was never in
any danger his mail is screened of
course and there's no chance that a
letter containing poison is ever gonna
make it to Trump's desk like that's not
gonna happen right so you might argue
that well that's the reason why it got
very little attention and it really got
I mean it I'm saying this right now I
think there are probably a lot of people
watching this or listening to this that
didn't even hear about
this might be the first time you're
hearing of it but it really did happen
recently someone mailed tried to mail a
poison to President Trump and maybe the
reason will be given for why why it was
news well because it was screened out
and never they never made it anywhere
near him you know so it was um so you
know he wasn't big news okay but the
pipe bombs were also not any threat to
their targets um the people screaming
Barack Obama's mail or Hillary Clinton's
mail they're not gonna hand them a
suspicious envelope with a heavy object
in the shape of a pipe drip bomb
protruding out the sides of it I mean
this whoever mailed this device mailed
it in an envelope in a suspicious
envelope so that you could even see the
shape of what appeared to be a pipe bomb
so there was just 0.0 percent chance
that those envelopes were ever going to
get anywhere near Obama or or Hillary or
any of the other targets but
interestingly enough the fact that the
attempt was a dud
was reason enough to ignore the story in
Trump's case but not in the case of
Obama's and Hillary's hmm another
example there was there was an attack on
the GOP at a congressional baseball game
hopefully you remember this an outspoken
Bernie Sanders supporter went to to the
game with a hit list of Republican names
with a loaded gun and a hit list of
Republican names he got to the game you
know he saw that there was some one of
the teams was out on the field
practicing he asked somebody which party
is that is that Republicans or Democrats
out in the field and the person said
Republicans and then the guy opened fire
representative Steve Scalise was nearly
killed in the assault so this was a
politically motivated pre-planned mass
assassination attempt targeting dozens
of GOP lawmakers at once this was far
more serious than the pipe bomb thing
because number one a politician was
nearly killed in the attempt and these
were live bullets being spray
directly at at you know at GOP
politicians but you know the media they
there was never any discussion about
toxic rhetoric MSNBC they told us that
toxic rhetoric began with Trump well
then how do you explain this he this had
nothing to do with rhetoric they said
Nancy Pelosi was even asked at the time
you know do you think that the
overheated rhetoric of a part of
Democrats may have played a part of and
she was out race she was indignant today
what anyone would even suggest such a
thing you know she paint she was the
victim because of that suggestion how
dare you even suggest that another
example you may remember in 2016 there
was a mass murder of police officers at
a black lives matter rally in Dallas a
murderous radical went on a rampage
during a BLM protest shot fourteen
police officers killed five of them but
the media took great pains to clarify
that the killer had nothing to do with
black lives matter liberals
the democrats nothing to do with it even
though many prominent leftist had spent
years up to that point claiming that
racist bigoted murderous police officers
are on the prowl hunting down innocent
black men and executing them in broad
daylight in the middle of the street
that's what they were telling us still
we were told that although people have
been saying that has nothing to do
nothing to do with the mass murder of
police officers at a black lives matter
protest and then and then finally well
this is just
me I say finally but just this is just
one other example I'm gonna sign I could
have said many more but remember the
riots in Ferguson in Baltimore this was
violence gripping the streets of
Ferguson and Baltimore for days on end
buildings were burned to the ground
stores were looted cars were set on fire
homes or vandalized people were were
assaulted by mobs I mean it was a
lawless chaos in the street and in those
in in nice especially with Ferguson but
Baltimore too but especially with
Ferguson which was the beginning of this
trend of riots and so on we can say
without a doubt that left-wing rhetoric
fueled and encouraged the violence
because liberals and Democrats people in
the media they were the ones spreading
the patently false hands up don't shoot
myth which became the rallying cry of
the rioters it was the reason why there
was a riot and it was a lie we could
also talk about the various and Tifa
riots we could talk about the you know
Republican politicians who have been
accosted by mobs chased out of
restaurants and so on but none of these
events prompted a national conversation
about dangerous rhetoric CNN never
blamed Obama for the Ferguson riot to
the Dallas MacOS Massacre MSNBC never
made Nancy Pelosi or Maxine Waters or
any or Chuck Schumer or any other
Democrat answer for the shooting spree
at a congressional baseball game the
media rejected the idea that anyone
other than the specific perpetrators
themselves could be responsible for
these attacks and only now have they
changed their mind on that but now
they're finally saying oh well actually
rhetoric could be to blame it is it's
truly despicable what they're doing and
we can't let them get away with it
and unfortunately calling calling them
out and calling them out for the
dishonesty and if you do that it's going
to open you to charges of what about ISM
but I think the the accusation of what
about is omits one of the cheapest
things that people do as if we're not
like if someone is making a claim and
saying well this is the first time this
is ever
happen then I'm allowed to say well no
actually here's some other times as well
and if someone is saying well there's
some Trump is it's creating this unique
environment of toxicity well if you're
claiming that then I don't have to just
sit here and listen to that lie I'm
gonna point out well no what are you
talking about GOP base like I can bring
that up I don't have to just sit here
and say and it allow you to spread that
false information that then that
propaganda now am I saying that every
attack by a liberal is the fault of
Democratic rhetoric no am i saying that
any attack could be the bullet could be
could be entirely the fault of rhetoric
no but am i saying that violent attacks
and rhetoric are two separate issues
that have no relationship at all no I'm
not saying that either so let me tell
you what I am saying on this issue of
rhetoric let's just talk about that for
a minute first it should be stated that
whenever somebody commits a violent act
the fault for that action lies
completely on the shoulders of the
person who committed it you know of
course even the most irresponsible
rhetoric in the world can't physically
cause someone to go out and shoot up a
baseball game or mail a pipe bomb or
whatever so we know that we can never
lose sight of free will personal agency
personal responsibility however it is
also absurd I think to pretend that our
words always have zero influence and are
therefore never a part of the story I
don't think that's true either there is
personal responsibility to go around
here everyone has personal
responsibility and we all have to be
responsible for our words so I do think
that certain kinds of rhetoric can
contribute to encourage foment chin-up
violence and unrest and people who
engage in that kind of talk when the
violence happens when the unrest happens
should also be given some of the blame
the people who commit the violent
actions they get 100% of the blame but
if someone did really encourage this
stuff they also get a certain portion of
blame so what kind of talk are we are we
talking about you what kind of talk am i
referring to what what what kind of talk
what kind of rhetoric could legitimately
be partially blamed for violence well
first of all talk rhetoric that is
incendiary and dishonest okay so the
problem with the hands up don't shoot
narrative is that it was untrue it was a
lie
it was a false narrative people who knew
better were deliberately spreading a lie
that they knew would stir up and was
stirring up outrage and violence and
mobs so do they share moral blame for
the ensuing outrage and thus did the
mobs and the violence that they incur
yeah of course they do
these were malicious lies
so maybe that's the way I put a kite a
certain sort of rhetoric that can be
partially blamed for about malicious
lies when you're telling lies
maliciously trying to get people angry
and upset so that was that was the thing
that was so evil and so terrible and why
we should really we should never forget
about what happened with Ferguson
because because the media they were they
were deliberately lying about what
happened even as city blocks were being
burned to the ground they were still
lying and they still lie about it to
this day they still won't admit that
this was all based on a lie so yes I
blame them at the time I still blame
them also um rhetoric that risks
explicitly calls upon people to engage
in violence so obviously if you're out
there telling people to do this stuff
then yes you you get part of the way
Maxine Waters told her followers to
quote create a crowd and get in the
faces of Republicans and make sure they
know they aren't welcome anywhere there
was a there was an editor for think
Think Progress who said that that
Republicans should be confronted where
they sleep which means at their homes he
was telling angry mobs to go to people's
homes so yes in in that case these
people are very clearly directly
encouraging calling for civil unrest and
violence and so when it happens is it
partly their fault obviously they're
specifically asking for it encouraging
it so obviously they share part of the
blame now here are some kinds of
rhetoric that are sometimes blamed for
violence but in my view cannot be blamed
and do not contribute to violence and
and and you know people should to blame
it for violence is is dishonest I think
tough but honest rhetoric okay if you're
if you're being tough if you're you know
using strong language but you're being
honest and what you're saying is true
then no I don't think you can be blamed
for violence so I'll give it I'll give
you an example for myself someone wrote
to me yesterday a Democrat wrote to me
it was respectful about it but they said
they said that they they agree with me
that a lot of our you know the political
rhetoric these days is toxic and it you
know and and so and so forth but they
they they challenged me and they said
well what about the things that you say
about abortion and about abortion
doctors you just said a couple a couple
days ago that abortion doc that every
abortion doctor is really no different
from karmak Gosnell that they're all
murderers they're baby killers aren't
you contributing to this and what if
someone goes and they should have an
abortion clinic isn't that partly your
fault for saying these things and my
answer to that is is no it wouldn't be
my fault because what I'm saying is true
now clearly I don't condone violence I
don't condone anyone going to an
abortion clinic and shooting it up which
is something that despite what the how
the Left presented its presents it that
very very rarely happens there have been
only a very few fatal attacks on
abortion clinics over the last several
decades it is a it is a very rare
occurrence but I don't condone it don't
encourage it it's evil it's wrong yet on
occasion it does happen does that mean
that I should stop saying that
abortionists are baby killers no because
it's true okay they're killing babies
it's
my fault they're killing but I wish they
wouldn't that's my whole point I want
them to stop doing it but they do it and
I don't have any obligation to ignore
this horrible reality because if I point
out the horrible reality it may
encourage a crazy person to go and do
something do something violent no I
that's no that's not how that works just
like Larry Nasser or Bill Cosby
if they get assaulted in prison is it
going to be the fault of all the people
who pointed out that these people are
despicable rapists you know if I go
around saying that Bill Cosby is a
serial rapist
Larry Nasser is a serial child molester
and then someone goes and assaults these
guys or kills them in prison is that my
fault because I said that no because
it's true and they are serial rapist so
can't be my fault abortion doctors are
serial killers I'm not gonna tone that
down I don't apologize for saying it
because it is true and my my my
recommendation to abortion doctors is if
you don't want to be called baby killers
stop killing babies that's what you
could do but as long as you do it that's
what I'm gonna call you I also don't
think that we can blame just general
partisan rhetoric for violence you know
that's part of politics a lot of it
isn't good I don't like a lot of it but
but that's just it's always been that
way that's how politics is so I just
don't think that if there's an explosion
of violence or something I don't think
we can blame partisanship in general and
then generally just obnoxious rhetoric
okay there are plenty of plenty of
people say insulting obnoxious things
it's not good we shouldn't do that but
that kind of thing is I don't think you
can blame that for violence either I
think again the the rhetoric that we
blamed for violence is the rhetoric that
explicitly encourages it or the rhetoric
that is dishonest
that is maliciously dishonest and
clearly in ten
to get the crowd stirred up and and all
that alright switching gears here for a
minute I want it to also talk about I
want to say something briefly about this
miss megan kelly situation the news is
that megan kelly is done at NBC they're
negotiating or exit right now the excuse
they're using it seems the catalyst for
this according to NBC are her comments
about black face on her show this week
now let me just say that this is this is
farcical and and first of all general
comments i you know general comment here
but I think megan kelly is the most
unfairly maligned person in all of media
she's hated art on both sides with an
intensity that is just weird and and
kind of grotesque there's no reason for
people to despise this woman the way
they do every megyn kelly controversy
every excuse people have used to dump on
her has been laughably weak in my
opinion i mean going back to I remember
years ago the first one I can I can
remember that I can think of is years
ago when she said that Santa Claus is
white and this became this huge thing
and everyone was outraged but it was
ridiculous
and ever since them it seems that people
are looking to rip this woman to shreds
for any reason they can find and and it
just seems unfair to me there was that
what was the thing but one of the one of
the first controversies on our news show
where she she was interviewing Jane
Fonda and she was she asked her
something about our plastic surgery or
something like that megyn kelly asked
Jane Fonda about something that Jane
Fonda has spoken about regularly
publicly but all of a sudden she was
supposed to know it's off-limits you're
not allowed to ask me that anymore and
everyone dumped on her for that so it's
it's um I don't know it seems like
there's there there may be a bit of envy
at work here
I can't otherwise explain the ridiculous
hatred for this woman there are a lot of
very unlikable people in media okay III
fully agree with that
there are a lot of people in media who
are who you just viscerally are
unlikable
I don't think megyn kelly makes even a
top 50 list in that regard and as to
this particular controversy over
Halloween costumes it seems we have
somehow managed to enter a new level of
PC insanity you know we we keep thinking
that it's gotten as bad as it could
possibly get and then it gets even it
gets it gets even worse yet again I mean
that she would lose her job over this or
partly over this or ostensibly over this
is is preposterous
there is nothing wrong with what she
said all she said was that a white
person may sometimes dress up like a
black person for Halloween or something
as a tribute not to mock black people
that's the point she was trying to make
is that yes there is there's a there are
you know examples in history of people
wearing so-called blackface to mock and
demean but she said well what if in the
year 2018 somebody a white person wants
to dress as someone from a different
ethnicity culture race but but you know
out of affection to pay tribute what's
wrong with that
now you could disagree you could
strongly disagree but to act like her
comments were somehow delusional or
completely beyond the pale or fueled by
blind racial hatred well that's that's
that is a that is a gross and willful
misconstrue love what you said
I know people never think about this you
know they never put themselves in the
shoes of the person being ganged up on
by the faux outraged mob but maybe they
should because I'll tell you if this is
enough to destroy a career if this
comment about Halloween costumes is now
enough if an innocent anak ewis opinion
about Halloween
costumes can now destroy a career well
then who knows you could be next if this
is enough and you agree with this then
you are helping to set a precedent that
you're not gonna like when it's turned
around on you and if you're cheering
this on then when the mob does come for
you over some innocuous innocent thing
that you said and the mob destroys you
and your life and your career well then
you know something you'll deserve it you
will deserve it when it happens to you
the people acting like megan kelly
really deserves to lose her job over an
opinion about a halloween costume that
every single one of them if it ever
happens to them they will deserve it if
you join in the mob dishonestly to take
someone's livelihood from them and their
job over over over over for a reason
that you know is completely bogus then
one of these days when the mob turns
around on you you will absolutely
deserve it final thing I want to mention
getting away from the news for a minute
Monday is my seventh anniversary with my
wife seven years I realize is is his law
is not quite long enough to go into wise
sage mode and start doling out marital
advice I think you have to hit probably
the quarter century mark for that so I'm
pretty far away from it still well I
think actually I think quarter century
or when your first kid graduates high
school I think when that has whichever
comes first that's when you can start
being the wise sage and doling out
advice so I'm not there I'm not even
close to that but I have learned a
couple of things through seven years and
three kids and I thought that maybe I
could mark this occasion by passing on
just the top two things that I've
learned about marriage in seven years
and so if you've been married a while if
you've been married longer than me then
there's no need to listen to this you
can just turn it off and stop listening
this is advice or insights
that I intend only for those who haven't
been married at all or haven't been
married very long because they came to
disagree with me they just have to
accept whatever I'm saying and assume
I'm right all right so two things that
I've learned I think I've learned
probably more than two things but I'll
give you two the top two the most
important two number one the first thing
that I've learned about marriage and
seven years probably the most important
is that women love pillows women love
pillows so much and if you're
the married yet you just don't
understand that you don't understand how
much women love pillows I have so many
pillows in my house so many pillows our
bed is covered in pillows our couch
pillows are everywhere we are drowning
in pillows and now my daughter five
years old she's picked up the pillow
addiction as well I you know there's so
there's a switch that flips in the
female brain at some point very early
we're all of a sudden they become pillow
obsessed I don't even know where my
daughter gets her pillows I'm not sure
who her pillow supplier is but she has
19 pillows on her bed she's she's you
know she's she's already gone down the
route of her mother and here's the thing
many of these pillows are not to be used
they are they are decorative pillows
decorative pillows a pillow that sits on
a bed or a couch for no reason and has
no function a think about a decorative
pillow on your bed that nobody will see
besides you so my wife puts pillows on
our bed that are only there for her to
look at for 10 seconds before she takes
them off the bed so that we can go to
bed this is I you know the decorative
pillow industry is 100% driven by
females if every woman on earth was
beamed into space by aliens tomorrow the
decorative pillow industry along with
the wrapping paper industry and the
Greek yogurt industry and the fancy soap
industry would all they would all
collapse overnight because this isn't
completely a female thing it is a
there's something biological
neurological about it I understand it
but this it's a female thing so we are
we've been drowning in pillows because
women love pillows but when I lived
alone as a bachelor for five years I had
one pillow to my name just one and I
used it on the couch and then I bought
brought it to bed at night that was my
one that was my pet I could have said to
you well here's my pillow because I just
had one and me and that pillow we had a
bond it was me and my pillow against the
world I didn't need anymore pillows you
know I had the one pillow but then I got
married and at some point very early on
me probably probably like in the first
week of our marriage my wife apparently
rented a dump truck and went to the home
goods distribution center
and bought every single decorative
pillow in the region and then and then
and then and then came and dumped them
into our house and my life has been
overtaken by pillows every since so so
that that's the first thing if you if
you're a man releases advice from if
you're getting married just realize that
your life will be overtaken by pillows
and never ever ever assume that you're
actually allowed to use any of those
pillows second thing I've learned
perhaps on a more serious note I've
learned in marriage and I know that this
is you know this will this will not
sound like a revelation and it's really
not but I have learned the necessity of
gratitude I think most people when you
ask them what's the most important
character trait to bring into a marriage
you know they'll say they'll say
patience they'll say loyalty they'll say
honesty and those are all very important
but I think that gratitude can make an
argument for belonging next to the big
three of fidelity honesty and patience I
think it really it's a big four because
I think you got to put gratitude there I
think gratitude is is is just as
important as those and I think more
marriages than we realize have been
destroyed for lack of gratitude I mean
there could be a marriage where both
both spouses are faithful honest even
patient but there's no gratitude
ruins the marriage the thing is as
everyone says marriages work and it does
require sacrifice it requires you to
serve the other person to care for the
other but when you begin to feel that
the other person doesn't notice what
you're doing doesn't care doesn't
appreciate isn't grateful and when that
feeling really metastasizes on to the
marriage like a cancer it can be fatal
for the marriage and I think this is
especially the case once kids are
involved because the thing about kids is
that they require a lot of work and a
lot of sacrifice and yet they will never
be grateful that's the thing about kids
they will never ever be great yes you
teach them to say please and thank you
but they will simply never understand as
long as they are children they will
never understand what you do for them
how hard you work for them how many
sacrifices you make for them they will
never understand the anxiety and the
heartbreak and the worry and the stress
and everything they will dig they can't
they they're not capable of
understanding it they won't understand
it and that is actually part of what
parents do part of the burden we carry
for our kids is that is that we you know
we shoulder these burdens so that our
kids can just skip merrily through life
not realizing that really any of it is
happening and that's and that's what
being a kid is all of us that's what
being a kid is supposed to be about and
they're just so they they can't be
really grateful for us because they
don't understand what we do and they're
not gonna understand it until years down
the line when they have kids of their
own and then they realize that oh yeah
right so parents especially mothers I'll
say get used to expending all of this
energy doing so much for their kids and
with very little appreciation and and
that's why it's even more important once
kids are on the scene for spouses to
appreciate each other and you know I'll
say in my situation my wife stays at
home with the kids and I know
I have to make sure that my wife knows
that I appreciate what she does because
it's hard work being a mom it's
emotionally draining it's physically
taxing and and aside from my wife might
you know aside from my wife herself I'm
the only other person in the family
capable of understanding what she does
and the burden she carries and therefore
being truly grateful for what for it the
kids aren't gonna understand it the dog
and the cat are gonna stay so I'm the
only other one that can so that's why
it's so important for me to be grateful
though I know that I still could stand
to improve quite a bit in the gratitude
department or at least in the expressed
gratitude Department I'm always
eternally grateful for my wife but part
of my job as a husband and father is to
express that gratitude to show it even
more importantly and to communicate it
in somehow and it's also of course
important for husbands to be appreciated
too fortunately I do feel appreciated in
my family but my wife does communicator
appreciation but but I know that there
are there are there are many families
where that's not the case I talk to men
who feel talking men all the time who
feel like they go to work they slave
away and a thankless job to provide for
their families they come home and
they're immediately thrust back into the
father role which is okay that that's
how it goes right but they get very few
breaks they get little rest they always
have the weight of providing and
protecting on their minds on their
shoulders weighing on their souls and
yet and yet you know some men feel that
their wives take all of that completely
for granted never express any gratitude
never appear to appreciate any of it
that's how some men feel and this again
is deadly for a marriage the wives of
those men they don't realize what
they're doing to their marriage and what
they're doing to their husband they
don't realize that their marriage is on
life support because their lack of
warmth in their lack of affection and
their lack of gratitude has turned their
husbands into shells
and there are plenty of husbands who
don't realize the same about their wives
I also think that that this is what you
know when we talk about this destroying
a marriage one of the ways that this
destroys a marriage is that this can be
a contributor to adultery though of
course again so you know someone someone
commits adultery that the blame for that
is entirely on them there's never an
excuse for that but but the reality is
we're human beings and you know we have
we have there are there are always
motivations and reasons behind our
actions so someone who commits adultery
there's always gonna be some some some
things contributing to it and motivating
it and I think a lack of gratitude can
can be a big contributor to that because
I could tell you I tell you what happens
like for the case of a man doesn't feel
appreciated it doesn't feel like his
wife really cares it doesn't feel the
affection the warmth from his wife and
you know he's got that for years and
then he you know meets somebody at work
who seems to really appreciate his
skills and his talent and seems to take
him seriously and seems to take an
interest and he starts to think why
don't get this at home and then now you
have the seeds of something very very
dangerous for the marriage and I think
the exact same thing can happen for
women who don't feel appreciated and
then they meet a man who oh wow this man
notices me he seems to appreciate my
presence in my existence and all of that
so gratitude is very important and it
let me just say one more thing about
marriage because I don't want I don't
want to wrap this up without saying this
I think it's important that you know I
love I love being married
I think being married is great I really
enjoy it I I have been single and lived
by myself and I've been married I was
single there by myself for five years
married for seven so you know so far
kind of an even sort of even between the
two I can and I can weigh them and I can
say I so much prefer
being married over that so much prefer
and I just think it's important for us
to say it's because because so often
when we talk about marriage we talk
about the challenges we say it's a lot
of work we say all the things that I
just said but I think it's important to
say these things because it's true
marriages work but I think people who
aren't married they listen to this and
they end it to them it sounds like wow
marriage sounds kind of miserable like
all it does what it's all it is is work
and sacrifice is there any joy in it and
so I just want to say yes there's a lot
of joy and it's great to be married and
I highly I recommend it to anyone I
highly recommend it there has never been
a moment I can say honestly there's
never been seven years I have not ever
for a moment wish that I was still
single I travel a lot for work I go out
and I speak around the country and so I
get I guess you could say more time to
myself than then a lot of married people
do because when I travel it just it most
the time it doesn't work to bring all
the whole family with me to go speak at
the fundraising banquets and so forth so
and and you know so I'm out of my own
I'm traveling and people will ask me say
well you know that might that must be
you must really enjoy that good time
yourself go away from the family and I
say yeah you know it's it's it's nice to
get a little time yourself at on
occasion but but no every single time
whenever I go whenever I go travel I
always wish that my family was myth with
me there's never a night that goes by
when I'm traveling where I don't think
to myself wow I wish I my family here so
I highly recommend it don't be fooled
into thinking that marriage is nothing
but but work it is work but there's a
lot of joy to be found in the work and I
think in my experience all true joy and
life comes from work so that's it that's
the end of my of my fortune cookie
reading for today have a great weekend
everybody I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed